the language I'm speaking right now is
on its way to becoming the world's
universal language for better or for
worse let's face it it's the language of
the Internet it's the language of
finance it's the language of air traffic
control of popular music diplomacy
English is everywhere now Mandarin
Chinese is spoken by more people but
more Chinese people are learning English
than English speakers are learning
Chinese last I heard there are two dozen
universities in China right now teaching
all in English English is taking over
and in addition to that it's been
predicted at the end of the century
almost all of the languages that exist
now they're about six thousand will no
longer be spoken there will only be some
hundreds left and on top of that it's at
the point where instant translation of
live speech is not only possible but it
gets better every year
the reason I'm reciting those things to
you is because I can tell that we're
getting to the point where a question is
going to start being asked which is why
should we learn foreign languages other
than if English happens to be foreign to
one why bother to learn another one when
it's getting to the point where almost
everybody in the world will be able to
communicate in one I think there are a
lot of reasons but I first want to
address the one that you're probably
most likely to have heard of because
actually it's more dangerous than you
might think and that is the idea that a
language channels your thoughts that the
vocabulary and the grammar of different
languages gives everybody a different
kind of acid trip so to speak that is a
marvelously enticing idea but it's kind
of fraud
it's not that it's untrue completely so
for example in French and Spanish the
word for table is for some reason marked
as feminine so La Table La Mesa you just
have to deal with it it has been shown
that if you are a speaker of one of
those languages and you happen to be
asked how you would imagine a table
talking then much more often than could
possibly be an accident a French or
Spanish speaker says that the table
would talk with a high and feminine
voice so if your friends are Spanish to
you a table is kind of a girl as opposed
to if you are an English speaker it's
hard not to love data like that and many
people will tell you that that means
that there's a worldview that you have
if you speak one of those languages but
you have to watch out because imagine if
somebody put us under the microscope to
us being those of us who speak English
natively what is the world view from
English so for example let's take an
English speaker up on the screen that is
it's bono he speaks English I presume he
has a world view now that is Donald
Trump in his way he speaks English as
well
and here is Miss Kardashian and she is
English speaker - so here are three
speakers of the English language what
worldview do those three people have in
common what worldview is shaped through
the English language that unites them
it's a highly fraught concept and so
gradual consensus is becoming that
language can shape thought but it tends
to be in rather darling
obscure psychological flutters it's not
a matter of giving you a different pair
of glasses on the world now if that's
the case then why learn languages if it
isn't going to change the way you think
what would the other reasons be there
are some one of them is that if you want
to imbibe a culture if you want to drink
it in if you want to become part of it
then whether or not the language
channel's the culture and that seems
doubtful if you want to imbibe the
culture you have to control to some
degree the language that the culture
happens to be conducted in there's no
other way there's an interesting
illustration of this I have to go
slightly obscure but really you should
seek it out there's a movie by the
Canadian film director Denis alcone read
out in English on the page Denis arc and
if you want to look him up he did a film
called Jesus of Montreal and many of the
characters are vibrant funny passionate
interesting french-canadian
french-speaking women there's one scene
closest to the end where they have to
take a friend to an Anglophone Hospital
in the hospital they have to speak
English now they speak English but it's
not their native language they'd rather
not speak English and they speak it more
slowly
they have accents they're not idiomatic
suddenly these characters that you fall
in love with become husks of themselves
that shadows of themselves to go into a
culture and to only ever process people
through that kind of scrim curtain is to
never truly get the culture and so to
the extent that hundreds of languages
will be left one reason to learn them
is because they are tickets to being
able to participate in the culture of
the people who speak them just by virtue
of the fact that it is their code so
that's one reason second reason it's
been shown that if you speak two
languages dementia is less likely to set
them and that you are probably a better
multitasker and these are factors that
set in early and so that ought to give
you some sense of when to give junior or
junior at lessons in another language
bilingualism is healthy and then third
languages are just an awful lot of fun
much more fun than we're often told so
for example Arabic Catawba he wrote Hyuk
- boo
he writes she writes um doob write in
the imperative what do those things have
in common all of those things have in
common the consonants sitting in the
middle like pillars they stay still and
the vowels dance around the consonants
who wouldn't want to roll that around in
their mouths you can get that from
Hebrew you can get that from Ethiopia's
main language Amharic that's fun or
languages have different word orders
learning how to speak with different
word order is like driving on the
different side of the street if you go
to a certain country or the feeling that
you get when you put witch hazel around
your eyes and you feel the tingle a
language can do that to you so for
example the cat and the Hat comes back a
book that I'm sure we all often return
to like Moby Dick one phrase in it is do
you know where I found him do you know
where he was he was eating cake in the
tub yes he was fine now if you learned
that in Mandarin Chinese then you have
to master you can know I did where him
fine
he was tub inside war Chen cake no
mistake gorging chewing that just feels
good imagine being able to do that for
years and years at a time
or have you ever learned any Cambodian
me either but if I did I would get to
roll around in my mouth
not some baker's dozen of vowels like
English has but a good 30 different
vowels scooching and oozing around in
the Cambodian mouth like bees in a hive
that is what a language can get you and
more to the point we live in an era when
it's never been easier to teach yourself
another language it used to be that you
had to go to a classroom and there would
be some diligent teacher
some genius teacher in there but that
person was only in there at certain
times and you have to go then and then
was not most times you have to go to
class if you didn't have that you had
something called a record I cut my teeth
on those there was only ever so much
data on a record or a cassette or even
that antique object known as a CD other
than that you had books that didn't work
that's just the way it was
today you can lay down lie on your
living room floor sipping bourbon and
teach yourself any language that you
want to with wonderful sets such as
rosetta stone I highly recommend the
lesser known glass akka as well you can
do it any time therefore you can do it
more and better you can give yourself
your morning pleasures in various
languages I take some Dilbert in various
languages every single morning it can
increase your skills couldn't have done
it 20 years ago when the idea of having
any language you wanted in your pocket
coming from your phone would have
sounded like science fiction to very
sophisticated people so I highly
recommend that you teach yourself
languages other than the one that I'm
speaking because there's never been a
better time to do it it's an awful lot
of fun it won't change your mind but it
will most certainly blow your mind thank
you very much
you